Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P.
This may be the most chaotic voicemail we've
ever received.
This is a guy who I guess has been call.
He says.
I haven't gotten back to him.
I'm not aware of ever having received a call
from this guy.
But he repeats just about every recent COVID
lie I can remember.
There's a kid crying in the background.
What sounds like his female partner is yelling
things to him to say this.
This almost is performance art of some kind
of avant garde nature.
Let's listen to it together.
Speaker 5: David Pakman This is Billy Harrison,
an A.D..
You still haven't hour.
Let me rephrase that.
I see you still haven't.
Speaker 1: So there's the kid in the background.
Speaker 5: Just chaos responding to my voicemails.
Either you're scared or.
Speaker 1: I'm not aware of any voicemails,
and I obviously, you know, I have a thousand
voicemails to listen to.
Right now, we obviously can't respond.
Speaker 5: Just like I said, you spread misinformation
and you don't know what to say back to me.
Like I said anything that you say, I can do
bone fragments unless you are mass, do not
work.
So we have peer
Speaker 1: reviewed our cities.
Masks work.
Speaker 5: That's a lie.
Vaccinations don't work.
That's a long.
Speaker 1: Vaccinations do so as well.
He sounds linguistically confused, he's saying
vaccinations don't work.
That's a lie.
Anyway, vaccinations obviously work very well.
You're 97 times more likely to die of COVID
if you're unvaccinated.
Speaker 5: The election was stolen.
That's true.
Speaker 1: The election was not stolen.
There's not even evidence that a single state
was stolen.
Speaker 5: Donald Trump was the greatest president
of all time.
That's true.
Speaker 1: No evidence of that, for sure.
Speaker 5: Everything that I can say, I can
back up.
What about you?
Speaker 1: Like us?
It's funny how people think asserting something
is backing it up, and
Speaker 5: I know it gave you my number and
everything else for me and you to go live
on your channel and your show and debate,
and I can prove you prove to you that you're
you're more.
And that's all you do is spread misinformation
by lies.
Speaker 1: I like the woman in the background
yelling lies and then he says, lies.
Yes, that's exactly it.
What a chaotic situation, huh?
Speaker 5: Yeah, you're going to take everybody
else's voice mails about you leaving the country.
I don't give everybody leave or you stay out
of
Speaker 1: the person in the background.
Feeding him lines is, I mean, you could if
this was a skit, you could not scripted any
better.
Speaker 5: I mean, oh, well, you make a serious.
Like I said, all of a sudden you talk about
Trump sort of playing bingo.
Why don't you debunk these?
He's saying saying, no, that's a lie.
This is what really happened.
That's what we do.
You can't.
You sit there and play Trump Bingo.
What about Biden and the Democrats, and you
can sit there and say that you're not a Democrat,
all you want to, and
Speaker 1: it's quite it's quite literally
the truth.
I've never been a Democrat.
Speaker 5: You're a Democrat, a Liberal Democrat.
A communist socialist Democrat.
Speaker 1: Meanwhile, the left is like, David,
you really should be a socialist.
Why aren't you a socialist?
Speaker 5: And if you ask, ask me, why?
And ask me the policies like you like to ask
everybody else?
Do you feel alive on your show and I'll make
you look stupid about the communist and socialist?
Speaker 1: I would love it for someone to
make me look like a communist like the first
question would be tell me one communist policy
that I support anyway.
That guy sounds like he's got a lot going
on.
I won't deny that it might be actually fun
if he called in, so hopefully he will.
He will call in during live calls.
We're going to talk about what is happening
with the Beijing Olympics on today's bonus
show very low viewership and also the the
quarantine hotels are being called quarantine.
Hell.
It's crazy what is happening.
We will also talk about alcohol returning
to flights in the U.S. and concerns among
flight attendants groups about it.
I would be concerned.
We'll talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show.
Sign up at Jawoyn at CNN.com.
Unidentified: We will speak to that.